nuts it's national donut day and donut
shops all over town are gearing up for
what we think is going to be a very busy
day so who better than to take a closer
look than our own ron futrell hey ron i
suppose you're at the donut bar downtown
what's going on out there
we are happy national donut day first of
all donut bar downtown on sixth street
and carson is where we're at they got
some special things planned today first
of all these birthday cake donuts give
it away free to anybody who stops by
here they've got an interesting
situation down here where they are open
until
they run out of doughnuts when they run
out of donuts they're done chef jeff is
here okay good good morning chef jeff
you you stay open until you run out of
doughnuts what's the earliest you've
ever closed 9 30
in the morning in the morning yeah it
was a valentine's day in 2016.
so are you expecting an early closing
today or you get plenty of donuts stay
around i hope so because i'm tired i
want to go home i've been up very early
okay jeff has been open here since uh
2016. yeah april april 4th
one of your special donuts this tell me
about this one the big papa tar so we
were featured on the steve harvey show
ellen ryan seacrest food network the
list goes on and on there's a whole
pop-tart stuff in there we have
strawberries s'mores and blueberry
not enough sugar
nope and then we also glaze it with uh
some strawberry jam on top crushed pop
tarts and then also inside wherever the
drizzle is is also um filled inside as
well which one should i try where should
we go here these these are for john okay
oh these are these are for johnson's
don't touch these i got one this is john
john these these are yeah he lives
downtown so he's gonna be the first one
in here so okay there you go so i got
you got one for me yes sir
long chocolate
oh
these are gourmet donuts by the way
yes i am talking with my mouth bowl um
gourmet donuts downtown las vegas who
are your clients you got to figure
lawyers um we have lawyers workers
mobsters tourists everybody
is trying this way
pay your awards look on your shoulder
here yeah that's just one of our awards
we're forbes usa today the list goes on
and on if you go outside you'll see all
our words on the outside window okay
there's only one of these the donut bar
downtown las vegas here fun place we got
to try some of these langler these are
for you i guess he wants me to bring
them not for me these these no not for
you chad
on the weekends we give kids free donuts
so bring them on down and if they don't
have kids bring the neighbors kids
bring them on down all right
is that enough for you john do you want
more no i think that you know i think
sharing is caring i think that's more
than adequate for my sugar grilled
cheese donuts made to order when you
walk in oh my gosh all right guys thanks
hey i'm headed to another donut place
i'm not going to tell you where but it's
my name is there's a clue to you my
first name all right i know which one
you're going to you think it's a spring
mountain but i'm staying here
okay you stay here keep working i got
ahead bringing the donuts back thanks
jeff you got it thank you
and donuts are so hard to get a donut
from that place every time always sold
out every time i go by oh we're already
closed so it's i've never been able to
sell out their stock and they're done
done for the day did you hear him just